[Music]
tea is the most popular drink in the
world
and there are countless ways we make and
consume it
but if you want to drink tea in the
oldest way we still know of
you'll first need to hike deep into the
remote tea mountains of southwest china
and hand-pick
leaves and buds from tea trees that are
hundreds of years old
it's a long way to go for authentic
chinese tea but one person
is doing it this great big story was
made possible by
[Music]
my name is xinhan tang i'm the owner of
trunk which is a tea house in new york
city
we specialize in historic chinese tea
historicities really represent the
pinnacle of tea culture
and these teas are usually not
mass-produced and they're trying to be
as authentic to the tea as possible it's
almost like
a masterpiece of music played versus a
practice
or a original piece of artwork versus
the copies
the masterpiece tea so to speak comes
from ancient tea trees that grow in the
wild
the only bud for 15 days out of the year
so chunan
must race each spring to find the trees
and harvest them in time
with the help of local farmers the best
tea trees are
always on some of the hardest to get to
places because
they need to be on very steep slopes we
usually motorcycle a little bit
sometimes we tread water sometimes we
climb in this region it's not uncommon
for tea trees to grow for several
hundred years
these tea trees right now is at its
prime
and this is what he is meant to taste
like
tasty once we
pick the tea we need to spread it out in
a
whole area where the water can travel
out before we can walk fry the tea
this step is to kill the enzymes so the
tea
fermentation can be stopped then we take
the tea
leaves out and then we roll the tea
once the sun dry the tea you need to
pick out any
discoloration this sorting process
usually takes
months to finish because we do have to
do them one by one with every single tea
months will go by before this tea is
ready to be poured out
but the journey is well worth it to
shannon
those extreme fine points in taste that
he
offers us i think it provides us a level
of joy that's beyond
anything else and my job here is to
preserve
this art and hopefully even push it to a
new height
you